[Music]
we have had a distinguished series of
leaders in the space program who have
addressed this community before they're
listed on the back of the blue program
which I hope you all picked up in the in
the past and that list is going to be
added to by an equally distinguished
member of our community
an old friend who has what arguably is
the best job in Washington at least the
best job in Washington for a scientist
the honorable Hantz mark is currently
the director of defense research and
engineering in the department of defense
which means that he gets to spend
enormous amounts of money doing anything
he likes as I understand understand his
job district description as well as long
as it has to do with the appropriate
innovative work in science and
engineering this is coming back home for
haunts mark who was a graduate student
in physics here back in the early 50s
and he told me that he's going to be
meeting with a number of his
contemporaries for for a reunion dinner
tonight he was working on Neutron
physics back in the days when the Van de
Graaff generators were over in East
Campus over where these East garages and
the constructions going on now
he served after his graduate degree as
acting acting head of the Neutron
physics group here at MIT in 1954 went
out to Lawrence Livermore Lab for for a
bit came back to MIT where he served as
a on the faculty as an assistant
professor of physics 1958 and 59 until
finally the pull of Edward Teller and
those of you who've met dr. Keller
understand how strong that pull can be
pulled akhter mark back to California to
the Lawrence Livermore laboratories
where he be he continued a very
distinguished career leading to his
appointment for nearly a decade on the
faculty
the nuclear engineering in at Berkeley I
crossed paths with dr. mark many times
each time I found it to be fascinating I
found him to be a man who took over who
had a wide range of interests first in
my experience was when I was doing
flight simulator research at NASA Ames
Research Center and dr. Marc was the
director of NASA Ames Research that are
covering a whole range of topics for
what would now be called astrobiology to
to planetary physics and was responsible
for the innovation of several of the
earliest satellites for scientific
exploration of the of the solar system
he after leaving it leaving NASA Ames in
in 1977 going to Washington I found I
bumped into him again when I was on the
scientific advisory board under under
professor covert and there was dr. mark
is under secretary under secretary of
defense and was trying to relate the
virtues as I told him today the virtues
of long-term R&D programs by referring
us back to the virtues of Isaac Newton
having supported the long-term
development of the of the cronograph dr.
mark has had more than his share of time
leading us in academia he is a professor
of aerospace education engineering and
engineering mechanics at the University
of Texas at Austin and at the University
of Texas he has been he was their
Chancellor of the Texas System from 1985
to 1992 dr. mark is a welcome addition
to those in the space community who have
had the opportunity to visit us here
here at MIT he's going to talk today
about something that he wasn't allowed
to talk about for many years and when he
gave me a choice of topics I said this
is the one we want to hit we want to
hear about because it was off in the
black world for so long dr. mark will
talk to us about space operations during
the Cold War on
[Applause]
okay is that excellent okay see I still
know how to do gadget soon I have to
apologize because in the Pentagon would
you believe her frugal see the biography
they send up was a duplex on two sides
Xerox on two sides and they only got the
first side and that's why the blue
saying doesn't mention MIT so I
apologize I really was here I remember a
lot of people here who haven't changed a
bit
and it's great to see all the new faces
so it's a pleasure to be here Larry
thank you so much for the invitation I
do want to talk about something that up
until 1994 was classified and what I am
permitted to say is really only won't
you come on down there more seats don't
don't be bashful just step over feet if
you want to walk around here and there
you go it was classified up until 1994
and the very existence of the
organization that conceived developed
built and actually operated the
satellites was classified so all of the
whole thing was was supposed to be
carried out under this umbrella I'll get
into the reasons for that assumed but
what really was interesting of course is
that the the classification was really
part of it fairly carefully I don't know
in the Pentagon they always make up
these slides so I'm sorry
yeah you need to know that Sheila would
know there's one of my successors is
secretary the Air Force but Sheila I
have to claim public credit for getting
you interested in the Air Force because
I was the one who got you on the Board
of Visitors of the Air Force Academy so
that was back in what 1979 or so 78
someone like that you haven't changed a
bit you still look great
let me start by just talking a little
bit about reconnaissance in general
aerial reconnaissance is is has a long
history because people use balloons for
aerial reconnaissance 200 years ago and
in the United States in the Civil War
that was the first time it was really
developed consciously and the first
aerial photograph actually was a picture
taken from a balloon here in Boston it's
a picture of downtown Boston with Beacon
Hill in the Capitol and all that and
it's a very nice high resolution picture
because it's taken basically by pinhole
camera so you had I don't know what the
nearest rating would be she live in I'll
show it to you sometime News rating is
an in-house term for resolution and so
on and so forth they they airplanes were
used in in for reconnaissance of course
in in combat and in World War two of
course aerial reconnaissance came into
its own
it was wild widely used and it was
decisive in in many instances for
example the Bismarck was spotted by two
by one by a PBY consolidate a over
thinking what was the name for those
things twin-engine was you almost had it
I'll remember in a minute and of course
in the Battle of Midway those same
airplanes also
were they were the decisive element in
in spotting the Japanese fleet the p38
was also they had a reconnaissance
version that was called f5 a and the
reason I mentioned that at all it was
designed by Kelly Johnson who later
designed the u2 and Johnson was was very
interested in reconnaissance from the
from the word go and the aerial cameras
interestingly enough were developed by
people here from MIT later itec and
other companies had spun off from MIT so
there is a long history of involvement
here at MIT in aerial reconnaissance and
of course the related field of photo
interpretation also became highly valued
and Constance Babington Smith who was a
Royal Air Force officer in World War two
was the person who identified the v2
rockets at Payne amended for the first
time and and come on in sit down yeah oh
yeah I hate to see people stand up
alright anyway she was the one who
identified those pictures for the first
time and alerted everybody to the fact
that there was something new coming on
now in after the end of the Second World
War
aerial reconnaissance of course is that
I don't think that's quite focused
[Music]
no that's good that's better than okay
all right
really the the principal reason for
reconnaissance was the Soviet nuclear
testing at that time the Soviet Union
was closed and one had to figure out how
to look at their at their nuclear test
sites to find out what they were doing
and the the first Soviet nuclear
explosion was in 1949 in September and
the debris from that explosion their
radioactive degree were picked up by a
by our b-29 a reconnaissance version of
the 29 and the first hydrogen bomb was
about four years later in August 1953 so
there was a reason for doing aerial
reconnaissance and I've already
mentioned Kelly Johnson
what was done of course was to develop a
high-altitude aircraft the u2 Kelly
Johnson designed that airplane and the
important point is this one here that
both the aerial reconnaissance the
advanced airplanes and the satellites
I'm going to talk about were developed
because of a committee that was headed
by Jim Killian who was at that time the
president of MIT and Edwin land who was
at that time the head of the Polaroid
corporation
I found out much to my pleasure that the
author of this biography of Edwin land
is in our audience here talk to
McIlhenny and I haven't seen I had this
is that must be the first biography of
land is that right yeah this is the
first biography of Edwin land he was a
remarkable person had a very strong
connection with MIT I think was an
Institute
so after a while isn't I believe that
after he quit Polaroid he came over here
to teach I worked with him briefly as it
when I was a graduate student here
interestingly enough the project that
was on was that he was asked by the
American Institute of Physics to give
they used to have these lectures on the
various topics in physics and he was
asked asked to give the lecture on
optics and he hired me to help him write
that lecture so I learned all almost all
I knew about optics from from Edwin land
a very very remarkable guy this
committee was set up in 1954 it was it
was actually chartered by President
Truman and the the I'm sorry President
Eisenhower the charge to the committee
was how do we do reconnaissance over
deny territory over the land Soviet
Union and the committee did something
that was very interesting they said
let's build this airplane the u2 and the
project for the u2 was initiated in
November 54 the first flight was in July
55 and the first operational mission was
in July 1956 I wish I could say that we
could do things like this as rapidly now
as we used to do them then the
remarkable thing about this committee
was that they said airplanes get shot
down at some point or other the Soviets
will learn how to shoot down the u2 and
we better have something in our back
pocket when that happens not if it
happens but when and so they also
initiated at the same time a program of
earth orbiting satellites as the
ultimate solution to the reconnaissance
business and that of course is the main
topic of my of my talk you do remember
that the u2 was shot down in May 1960
and what is remarkable is that the first
reconnaissance satellite was launched a
couple of months later
yeah come on in soon and we got plenty
of room all you have to do is step on a
few toes but now satellites earth
orbiting satellites were you know the
subject of science fiction for a long
time but the first really serious
calculation of what you'd have to do to
get an Earth orbiting satellite into
orbit and do something useful with it
was made in 1946 by a group at what was
then the Douglas Aircraft Corporation
and then spun off to be the RAND
Corporation and that was called the
preliminary design of an experimental
world circling spaceship and in that
report one of the major reasons for
doing this was to say if you put a
camera on this thing and look at the
earth you can do military reconnaissance
so that was from the very beginning in
1946 something to do I've already said
that the program was initiated in 1955
and there were really two distinct
programs that were recommended by the
Killian land committee the one was
essentially a program that was supposed
to observe missiles that were being
launched and the other one was a program
to take high-resolution pictures to
judge what technical capabilities the
Soviets were developing as I've already
mentioned the u2 was shot down in May of
1960 in October the first samos
satellite was launched the first
photographic satellite was launched so
the kilian land committee the parallel
recommendation that we do high-altitude
airplanes and satellites at the same
time turned out to be a very
important thing that launch was a
failure but the first successful flight
was carried out in 1961 the codename for
this thing was Corona
more than a hundred Corona missions were
flown I think it was if in fact 152 if I
remember correctly the program was
terminated in 1972 and has been
Declassified since 1994 and I'm going to
talk about that in some detail and then
I can talk about other things that we've
done because some of the other things
have been Declassified but they will be
stories rather than detailed detailed
data let me this is one final word chart
there was a debate as to how to run this
satellite program and they there were
there were really three considerations
and that's the first bullet up there
first of all the the customer was the
president so that the the word national
and National Reconnaissance Office means
that it was set up to serve the
president's requirements to know what
was going on both civilian and military
people would be involved because there
was a mix of civilians and military who
had capabilities in this business and
that meant that you couldn't give it
simply to a military service you had to
kind of mix it up and create something
new and the last point is that secrecy
must be deserved preserved and that
secrecy really had two separate reasons
the first was that you are gathering
intelligence and you don't want the
gather the gather ease the people you're
gathering on to know how good you are or
how bad you are or what you know or what
you don't know and so there was
technical secrecy but there was an even
more important reason for secrecy by
this time Khrushchev was in office there
were still you know problems but it was
really the era of the thaw you remember
there were there were summit meetings
began the coldest part of the Cold War
was really kind of over and the Russians
let us know that okay we know you're
gonna do these satellites but we'd
rather not that you talked about it it
would be harmful to our own position in
the Soviet Union and we'd like you to
keep this very secret that's all we said
yeah we could have to keep it secret
anyhow and so secrecy therefore was
agreed upon tacitly by both sides it was
also a kind of secrecy where there were
over the years calculated leaks because
as you as I will tell you shortly one of
the very important things that we did
with these satellites was to do the
monitoring of arms control treaties and
consequently it was important for people
to know in quotes that we could indeed
monitor them without telling people
overtly that we were doing it and
certainly without giving away the
capabilities of the systems and so there
was kind of an interesting situation
where when I was serving as director of
the National Reconnaissance Office in
the late 1970s were a newspaper man
would call you up and
say you know what's going on with
monitoring such as such and I would say
what are you talking about and well we
know you're head of the NRO I said
what's that so we had this rather
strange situation where people would
would know and then we would have to say
a few things and finally we'd kind of
wink and you know say something that
somebody in the white house in the house
or in the State Department had decided
that yeah they ought we oughtn't let
people know that that we can detect such
and such or this and that so it was it
was a secret organization that had an
important public function and the public
function of course was to create
confidence in the public that we could
indeed enter into these treaties in such
a way that we could know that they were
being honored
anyway the solution to all of this was a
single organization the National
Reconnaissance Office and it was to
conceive develop build and operate
satellites it did all the four things
that's a unique thing the director of
the NRO was a senior member of the
intelligence community and the Under
Secretary's position in the Air Force
was the cover name for that so in my
biography it says I was undersecretary
the Air Force what I was really doing is
is this now there's another interesting
thing about the NRO because the head of
the NRO is the only other civilian in
the Pentagon who actually has command
authority over the military you see the
Secretary of Defense has command
authority through the the chain to the
president and then to the chairman of
the Joint Chiefs and so on the head of
the NRO commands a military organization
the ground stations the the various
facilities necessary to run the
satellite systems are manned by the Air
Force and and sometimes by the Navy so
there are there are military
organizations and these organizations
actually take direct orders from the NRO
staff so the NRO is in an in a very real
operational sense a military
organization it is interesting that when
I was director it's now become of course
now that it's Declassified it's it's
much larger for one thing a lot of other
things were incorporated they have a
fine building now in Chantilly Virginia
if you ever go go I was absolutely blown
away when I saw this thing with the NRO
letters on it which were which were
totally secret in my day we were we were
hiding in a in a small office suite in
the Pentagon in the see ring which is
you know way below the salt so to speak
but now it's a fancy office but it's
also different it's changed and it has
in addition to the responsibilities it
used to have which were primarily
peacetime reconnaissance it now also has
a large job of supporting military
operations and so it's really a very
different kind of thing today than it
was in the years that I headed it and I
say I was director from 19 1977 too late
79 about two and a half years and that
was sort of the the height of the
mission where our primary mission was
arms control because you'll remember
that in the Carter Administration
assault two was coming on and the
president's major function was to try to
major objective was to push that through
and in order to do that we had to
demonstrate that we could actually
monitor the monitor of the treaty the
office was chartered in 1960 and Jo
Charak was the first first director now
let me talk about physics and
engineering for a while not for the
politics the first photographic
reconnaissance satellite that was really
an operation
vehicle is this one here this is the
corona satellite kh4 was the was the
code word for it and this thing was a
rather large thing this is it was about
gee lose it see if I didn't work this
thing good this was about maybe 15 feet
by 7 feet so it's a big thing and it was
a photographic camera this is the film
roll and here are the the two cameras
there were two cameras to pan panning
cameras and I'll show you a diagram of
this thing shortly and they they the
film was exposed in a cassette up here
and the camera rotated and as the as the
camera the lens rotated past the ground
here it would put the image on this it
would scan the image on this film and
when the camera wasn't looking at the
ground the film would advance and then
it would take the next one and you had
two cameras and you rotated them in
opposite directions so that the moment
of inertia's cancelled out and so you
had a spacecraft that you could easily
control it was a pretty clever design
there were also up front here what we
called the buckets and these were the
take-up spools for the film there were
two buckets on this thing this is the
first one and here's a second one here
and these have heat shields on them and
these were recovered we would drop these
off and recover them and the way this
thing worked is that it was recovered
near close to Hawaii
we had a squadron of airplanes here I'll
show you a picture of one shortly and
there we had rigged up a way of snagging
the things coming in on the parachutes
and then we would call them we did this
several hundred times and in that period
only two buckets were lost which was
kind of a pretty good record let me show
you some more details on this thing
by the way this the the cage for is you
could this you can see this in the
Aerospace Museum this is a kind of a
blown-up model of the cage for here the
- this is one camera and here's the
other one
and the spool is here and then here's
the first bucket and the second one was
here and they took the shield off so
they could show how to take up spool
work then this is about the size of it I
don't know where they have it now when I
took this buck this picture they had it
right after they put the exhibit up
they had it next to the escalator Sarah
in the in the museum here's a top view
of this thing and again you can see the
the general structure of this thing this
film I think was about 125 millimeters
something like that I can't quite
remember it but it's a pretty big it's a
big film and of course you had a very
good the the the this the telescope the
optical system had a 15 centimeter lens
on it let me show you a line drawing so
that you can get a little more details
on that and then we'll get to figure
showing you how the geometry actually
worked this is the the line drawing so
that here's the film spool here are the
two cameras here are the two buckets and
then there were other things of course
you had to stabilize this thing in in in
space so you had to have star sensors to
keep it locked onto to a star and it had
to be stabilized very carefully because
if you want high resolution you don't
want the camera to to vibrate so that
was one of the one of the really
technical problems here was to develop a
guidance system that
gave you really a good three axis
stabilization so that you could take
these pictures there and you had to have
of course three references and one was a
star there was a horizon sensor and I
don't quite remember how the rest of it
worked but I can I'll have some pictures
of it later on so you can yeah here in
fact here it is here is kind of a a a
line drawing of how this how this thing
worked the satellite this is kind of a
cutaway that shows only the cameras and
then the star sensor there wasn't
there's an index camera to number the
film and there is a horizon camera here
which stabilizes the thing against
against the horizon these were our
nearly circular orbits and they were low
orbits of the order of 100 miles hundred
nautical miles or so now and and I've
already said the cameras rotate around
and in as they rotate they pan across
this this these things on the ground
here this is about a hundred and fifty
nautical miles by 150 nautical miles and
the the cameras as already said are our
counter contra-rotating and of course
when you do this you get stereoscopic
images that's one of the things that
that was really important about this
thing that we could get a good stereo
stereo stereo images but this is kind of
the way the the thing worked and of
course as it flew in orbit around the
world it covered a lot of territory let
me show you the territory covered in a
sample mission this is in in one mission
these were the pictures that were taken
used to last a few days maybe a week or
two before you brought the brought the
buckets back
you can sort of see that the target was
the evil empire at the time so and these
these were chosen for various reasons
missile fields or industrial centers or
something Middle East was of interest
then and so was I think this was may
have been at a time when India and China
were having problems so this was was was
taken here China is a target Korea of
course is was and it still is a target
but this a the the a sample mission
would run something like three million
square miles so you really you've got
say one United States in each in each in
each mission got it okay now I promised
to show you how the things were picked
up this was an old Fairchild
c19 and they had this had a had a back
door we finally used one 31 30s for this
rather than these airplanes but you'll
notice there was this rig out here and
this loop here caught the parachute
here's the bucket there was the
parachute and you'd fly along and watch
the parachute come down and the pilot
would fly over it and catch it and pick
it up I I went out on one of these
missions and it was it was kind of fun
these were US Air Force airplanes and we
had a sometimes we had a helicopter when
the thing was close enough to why we had
a helicopter down there to fish it out
of the water if we missed it but that
was the way these buckets were were
picked up from the Corona system you'd
have your data back within a couple of
weeks so it wasn't totally real-time but
it was pretty good this is the first
satellite photograph from a famous
mission of an airfield in eastern Russia
taken on August 18th 1960 and here you
can see the runway and the tarmac the
flight line
the resolution wasn't very good because
we hadn't learned really how to tweak
this thing yet but that that is kind of
historical because that's the first one
and again let me repeat the remarkable
thing is that it was taken a few months
after the u2 was shot down and and you
know for didn't land and Killian and
those people to sit down and say hey the
airplanes are gonna get shot down we'd
better start on satellites and then to
arrange the program so that satellites
were ready when the airplane got shot
down was really something something
quite unique I thought now I told you
that that the the real the real reason
for this was the counting of the
strategic weapons and this is a typical
picture that was taken in 1962 of a ICBM
site here and the support areas and and
all these things people always ask me
you know did the Soviets do the same
thing to us the answer is they they had
reconnaissance satellites but they
really didn't need them because you can
drive around the United States and and
see these things out west and their
locations are public knowledge so it's
it's no big deal
anyway this is this is a missile site
early on very early on in the early 60s
it became apparent that one of the
things that the NRO
could do and did was to help with
various disasters now this was not a
disaster this was a
volcanic eruption on the Kamchatka
Peninsula and the you can see the there
is a the the Sun was over here let's you
know I always get confused here this is
the lava flow that this is a shadow of
the cone of the volcanic cone here and
then there is a steam vent over here the
main point is that you could very
quickly analyze what was going wrong in
a volcanic explosion I remember during
my term as director there was a major
eruption of a volcano in South America
in Colombia and there was a real
disaster with a what happened was that
this mountain had snow on it and of
course when the top blows off the snow
turns into water that turns into mud and
it goes down the side of the mountain
and sweeps everything out of its way we
were able to spot with our satellites
isolated people that were had to be
rescued and of course we then once we
had the satellite pictures we deployed
u2's and these reconnaissance
capabilities have been used for disaster
mitigation all along I remember we also
had an earthquake in Mexico City that we
monitored and and looked at we actually
Declassified some of the pictures even
under my when I was director and what we
did was we fuzzy the resolution so that
that we could we could declassify them
and then just gave them to the to the
rescue people who had to have to do the
job of course China became a target when
they became a nuclear power this is the
first Chinese nuclear test in 1964 this
is the crater here they the Chinese test
site always had these circular exclusion
zones
I don't know how they do these circles
on the ground but it's it's kind of
remarkable that they really had this
unique thing that before they run an
explosion somewhere they they'd they'd
have a circular excuse you see you this
one here they had these they had these
circular exclusion zones but that's 1964
I'd love newer this is in western China
here is it a typical picture that was
taken during the mid 60s for reasons of
arms control arms control this is a
Soviet strategic airbase and this is a
long runway and here you can see you
can't see him very well this is I should
have been large the flight line here but
there are about 50 heavy bombers these
are a mixture of the Badgers and the
backfires that they had at the time I'm
sorry that's too early for the backfire
this was these are badgers and and 97 to
97 and they were on this line here and
they were about 50 of them and of course
in the arms control negotiations the
question of how you count these things
was was important and really the early
satellites were terribly important in
giving people confidence that you could
do that you could do the counting one of
the things that happened to me when I
was director is that I've already
mentioned that President Carter wanted
to do salt too we had an arrangement
with the Congress when I became director
in 1977 that the National Reconnaissance
Office would get a billion dollars a
year no questions asked
there were only two people in the
Congress who were cleared at the time
and they were the
two heads of the intelligence committees
not even the Armed Services Committee
people were cleared and there were no
staffers clearly and the the budget was
was hidden in the airforce budget and
the airforce budget is big enough so the
billion dollars here and there didn't
attract too much attention but what
happened in 1977 was that that salt too
was a treaty that was quite
sophisticated in the things that had to
be monitored and I remember spurgeon
Keaney who was at that time the deputy
director of the arms control agency came
to me and said what can we do with your
systems we have because we we had better
write a treaty that's consistent with
what we can monitor and in our talk we
came to the conclusion that we really
couldn't write a treaty beyond salt one
that would be reachable by the current
system that we had and so we decided
that we would go to President Carter and
say look if you're gonna do the salt 2
then we need more satellite systems and
I remember the the Keeney his boss was
Paul Warnke we went to see the president
and Carter said well how much do you
think it'll cost and so I you know
horseback guess was another billion
dollars turned out to be - by the way
when I left the NRO we had a budget of
three million billion and the president
said okay I'll go do it but then he said
you know we're not gonna get this
through the Congress and so 1978 was the
first year when we had to go and clear a
lot of people in the Congress because in
order to break that billion-dollar
barrier we really had to go tell more
people about it and so really for the
first time the NRO had to establish the
normal kind of relationships with the
with the Congress we what that meant was
that we had to make some pictures that
people would would see I'm showing you
one that looks like one of those
pictures I can't show you the real
one because it's took still classified
but what we did was we took pictures of
things around Washington this is the
Washington Monument here and the reason
we I had a very good resolution picture
of this thing for for here's the the see
I gotta get myself oriented here this
must be the bridge yeah there's the 14th
Street bridge and this is I think the
Agriculture Department and it goes down
this way anyway this is this is the
Washington Monument and of course the
important point is that sometimes you
want to know how tall a missile was and
you do that by looking at the shadow and
the Sun angle and I remember we had a
picture like this for the people in the
Congress where we could say hey fellas
we can tell how big these things are and
of course once we started doing that I
remember going around the halls of the
Congress with these pictures showing
them to the people hood who had recently
been cleared and of course one thing we
always did was to take a picture of the
of the Pentagon and those of you who
have lived in the Pentagon will know
that there's a hamburger joint down here
which is called Ground Zero and in the
summertime we go ahead and lunch there
now one of the very interesting things
that came out of the later missions and
I'm showing you now a picture that was
taken with infrared film was the
assessment of Soviet agriculture you
remember that the Russians a number of
times the Soviets a number of times
cornered the grain market and we want to
prevent that and to do that we had to
estimate what their yield would be and
the way that was done was to fly these
things with infrared film and then it
turns out unfortunately I don't have a
color picture of this
it turns out that that the individual
crops have have rather unique signatures
so that if you say have a three filter
camera you can kind of tell whether
you're looking at wheat or corn or
vegetables or things of that kind and
this is an example of Lompoc California
where there's a lot of truck farming
around here and we did this
systematically with the Soviet Union and
predicted the yields better than they
could and eventually of course we told
them that and they said well why don't
you tell us what you're learning and it
it is now of course this as you know is
a commercial thing now you can buy these
pictures and and people who are in the
agricultural business do so here's
another another interesting picture this
by the way is one of the best pictures
that was taken by the by the corona
system this is the shipyard and
Severodvinsk which is up on the white
White Sea they built their submarines in
this building this is a huge building
here and then what these were basins
that they fill up when they launched a
Selman this was taken in February so
this whole harbor is frozen over in fact
you can see tracks of vehicles here that
they if they ran on the snow on the ice
rally the resolution this thing is about
foot and a half here are this the the
docks here's a submarine and these were
the docks were the finished ships were
the the nuclear fuel was installed here
in this in this area I remember one one
amusing incident was that we had a
problem that we
and somehow miss counted the number of
submarines the Russians had they had
more than we thought they had and there
was there was rather that was rather a
mystery for a while until we saw a
submarine here at this dock and it
looked like a black missile sub and then
the that night there was a storm and
when the next picture was taken the
submarine was bent into a 90-degree
angle
and the mystery mystery was solved
because they had made some dummy
submarines out of basically out of
rubber I guess and had parked them in
with the other submarines and it wasn't
until we saw this one that was destroyed
in the storm that we realized what they
had what they had done so there there
was a certain amount of a certain amount
of kind of cops and robbers that went
with this with this thing there's
another reason why this picture is clear
by the way because at northern latitudes
when there's no wind the air becomes
very very transparent and very very
still all the Junkers is condensed out
and it gets cold up there so you really
have a very clear view here is another
interesting picture I showed you the
pictures of Washington and of course we
have to be I have to also show you
pictures of Moscow this is the Moscow
River here and here's the Kremlin and
here's an enlargement of the Kremlin and
what was interesting about this picture
is that this was 1970 here are the
people lined up to go into Lenin's tomb
see the line of people so eventually we
got to the point where we could actually
see individual people on the ground I
remember you know the the only time
Shelagh that I ever
called by a president was by President
Carter he called usually for two reasons
one was when we didn't give him the
pictures that morning and he wanted to
know what the hell happened and he was
an engineer so he wasn't satisfied with
just it isn't working he wanted to know
why the other time he would he would
call was for serious things this
business of looking at people was
important once when the the Chinese
invaded North Vietnam in 1979 478 I
think it was and the Russians remember
that North Vietnam was was really a
satellite of Russia and China was rather
ambivalent about this whole business of
the war there and so on and after the
war was over they invaded North Vietnam
and I remember the Russians threatened
to invade China and we got a call from
the White House saying is this credible
and so we targeted the border between
Russia and China with our satellites and
I remember the first pictures that came
back I looked at them and there were you
know troops out playing soccer and you
know doing things that may well it was
crystal clear that they weren't
mobilized they weren't ready to go
anywhere
and we showed those to the president we
said look the Russians are bluffing
that's the kind of value that the
president put to to satellite
reconnaissance because by doing this
kind of thing you could kind of gauge
intentions which which was important in
that same incident we also discovered
something else that was interesting and
let me digress for a minute from these
satellites and talk about other things
that we do from space which are still
highly classified but I can't talk about
I can't talk about how well we do it but
I can't tell you
that we intercept messages in space and
we watched the Chinese invasion of North
Vietnam and intercepted the chatter the
traffic
the radios voice radios and I remember
one listening to one tape were were guy
commanding a tank column says we were
coming down this road but the North
Vietnamese have artillery on the hill
over there and they're gonna shoot at us
and we're about out of gasoline so I'm
not gonna go in there and then be a
sitting duck and so the colonel back in
the says you you better go and so then
the captain in command of this tank
platoon says what where's the gasoline
and so he the colonel said you'll get it
you'll get it soon so we were kind of
interested in this whole incident and we
targeted it with our photo satellite and
what we discovered was that these tanks
were sitting in front of this artillery
position the captain did not in fact go
until he got his gasoline and he's got
his gasoline by a mule train that came
up with kanessa lean commands jerry cans
on on either side and that gave you an
insight into the logistical capabilities
of the chinese army i mean they they had
water tanks they had modern comm gear
but the gasoline came up with mules so
these were were the kind of kind of
incidents that that's right we had by
then we had we had electro-optic we had
real-time imagery we had electro optical
systems so that I just mentioned the
fact that the the breakthrough here was
seeing individual people and from then
on we got systems that could could kind
of do that
we also did a lot of economic work this
was kind of interesting because gold is
another thing where the Soviets had a
lot they had they had a lot to do with
with the gold market and so on and and
and we used to target their placer
mining this you see you can see this
kind of thing all over California it's
basically you fill up a basin here and
you run a dredge in it and then these
are the remains of the placer mining and
this is a more accurate picture of the
dredging operation here but the
interesting thing is that the side
information we got here is that they
that there was a logging area next to
this and they were clear cutting this
mountain so we learned that they were
sure as hell digging gold and that their
logging techniques were essentially to
clear-cut large areas now they have a
lot of forests many more than we have
but that these are the kind of things
that that were we're pretty common and
these were sort of accidental targeting
rather than then deliberate ones let me
just run through these very quickly this
is an IR BM complex this was very
controversial because people worried
about ranges of rockets and should they
be in the treaty or out of the treaty
and so on so we did a lot of work on
that
this was 71 this was almost before this
remember this program was shut down in
72 so by this time we already had better
satellites we also made some some very
interesting archaeological discoveries
served pretty much by accident this is a
remains of a Roman fort in in Jordan and
this was the this is underground by the
way this was this was you can't see it
from the ground but you can see
here's here's some modern buildings but
it was really located first by this
satellite picture and probably the most
interesting environmental things that
we've done have to do with the fact that
the corona system started in 1960 and so
we have 12 years of history that we
didn't know about until this thing was
Declassified in 1992 of a 94 rather and
you remember the the the stories about
the Aral Sea were published for the
first time in that year and the reason
was that we had pictures of the Aral Sea
as it was before they the real problems
began because and what happened was that
the russians encouraged mass
immigrations
to the regions to the south of the aral
sea where the rivers see there's a
mountain range down here in the south
just part of the himalayas actually and
the snow the runoff from those mountains
fed the RLC and what they did was they
encouraged agriculture in this area down
here that came from rivers that was
irrigated by rivers that came from these
mountains here and so the Aral Sea
didn't get any any water and it
evaporated and you can see this picture
here was taken in 1962 and this was 1994
32 years later and so these extra 12
years gave us a real picture of what
happened there and of course we this is
only one example there are there are
numerous example of this where we
actually could extend the period that we
were where we were monitoring various
environmental
environmental things let me wind up now
just with one other slide here and this
is kind of a summary of the the
achievements of the of the system I
mentioned this one here and I really
think this is the most important thing I
don't think we have any arms control
treaties if it weren't for the
satellites we had technical capabilities
I should let me tell you another story
that that was interesting I ran an
aeronautical laboratory for a while in
the 1970s and how many of you in this
room have heard of something called the
caspian sea monster now a few of you I
better tell you the story of the caspian
sea monster then in the early nineteen
late 1960s it was one of our addresses
in moscow in those days you got to
moscow by going through Tehran you flew
an American to Tehran and then you flew
our flight up to Moscow this guy was
flying on the air slot airplane over the
Caspian Sea and there in the Caspian Sea
he saw looking down a huge airplane
flying at low altitude the thing had I
don't remember she only had canards I
think and two engines on the cars and it
had wings with three engines under each
wing and then it had a high tail with a
couple of more engines on the tail I
mean it was really bizarre and I
remember I was sitting at Ames at the
time and and of course Colonel came by
and with some pictures of this thing
that had come out of the the NRO and he
he showed him to me and he said can you
tell me what this is you know so I said
well I if you can get me some better
pictures maybe we can make some wind
tunnel models and actually test the
thing in the wind tunnels and find out
what the
how the thing works and so we got some
quite good satellite pictures of this
thing in flight in the water on the ramp
and so on they built about four of these
I would say but they were 747 sized
aircraft and probably heavier because
they had more engines and it was they
were kind of low-tech machines and I
remember reporting to the what was then
called the foreign intelligence division
at Wright Field and I went there and I
gave him the results and I I gave a
little talk about it and I said whatever
it is it doesn't fly very well it's just
not a good airplane and that it would
only work in ground effect that is
really only work at low at low you know
maybe 50 feet above the ground but not
better and so you know the mystery was
what were they gonna do with this thing
and so for years the caspian sea monster
was always on the top of the agenda of
all these intelligence committees and so
on and i finally when I became Secretary
of the Air Force one of the things that
happened was that the foreign
intelligence division came by and they
sure enough on the top of the agenda was
the where's the caspian sea monster so i
said you mean you're you're you're
really still worrying about this thing
and they said well yeah but we got to
figure out what it is i said i'll tell
you what it is it's a screw-up
you know they know what they were doing
and and then i said it is the nature of
the soviet union that it is highly
probable that the vice admiral who runs
this program is married to a cousin of a
member of the Politburo and they don't
know how to shut him down so this was
the this was several times we had we had
things like this and seriously one of
the characteristic things about the
Soviet Union and probably one of the
things that drove him under eventually
was that they do not have
the review system we have here the
adversary system and so what that means
is that they'll start a program and we
had a number of facilities like this
that were truly mysterious because we
really couldn't say well they don't
quite know what they're doing because
maybe they knew more than we did so we
always had to be a little careful but
they don't have the both the classified
and the unclassified adversarial system
we have here or you know the the public
discussion over whether some weapon
system is useful or whether it works and
so on is one of the most valuable things
we have in this country because it it's
a filter and it really prevents us from
doing a lot of nonsense and I think that
that that that's one of the important
lessons out of this thing I ought to
talk about the South African nuclear
test program that was also interesting
that also happened on my watch
I remember we got a call from somebody
in the State Department and the guy said
come on over and I want to talk to you
so I went over and he had a cable that
came in from the Russians which
essentially said there's something
interesting going on at the coordinates
such a certain and such and such in the
Kalahari Desert and the guy in the State
Department said can you do this and so I
said well then I said sure sure we can
do it we can target that but why do you
want to why do you want to know well the
Russians think there's a there's a
nuclear test about to be made there and
so I said well alright why don't you
why'd you tell him well what happened
was it that we sent them a cable which
said nonsense it isn't so so we better
find out whether it is or isn't and so
all right
I took I probably targeted the
satellites on this thing and sure enough
you know I'd been in the nuclear test
business when I was at Livermore and and
sure enough this thing was I was in a
and a a precise facility for an
underground nuclear test there's a hole
in the ground pad around it then a few
hundred feet away there was a block
house just everything could have and
they I went back to the guy in the State
Department I said you know you fellas
should have done this before you told
the Russians nonsense this is a nuclear
test site and basically the reason the
Russians gave us the information was
that they wanted us to put pressure on
the South Africans to stop it and so you
know the State Department cables South
Africa and said knock it off and then
they called me back and they said well
we told him to knock it off would you
please check and see whether they
actually did so we continued to target
this thing for the next few weeks and
they pulled that thing out of the ground
toot sweet it was gone in a week the
hole was filled in the buildings were
blown and the trucks took everything
away they never ran a test on the
continent and but they did build weapons
you know they did learn how to separate
uranium to do you 235 and so again we
could we could tell that well I think
I've kind of covered all this stuff and
why don't I quit here and I'll be happy
to answer any questions if that's if
that's appropriate
so I thinking here you yeah yeah thank
you thank you very much dr. mark
[Applause]
before before before pausing for
questions let me present you with our
certificate of appreciation how to fill
in whatever interspaces there may be on
the wall in the Pentagon and I tell you
at my stage the only things I have on my
wall and the Pentagon are pictures of my
grandchildren okay sounds like a good
stage questions Sheila Cronin was shut
down in 72 we had several other film
systems that are still classified and we
did the first real time in 78 and again
I was there was when I was director of
the NRO and that was kind of a really
interesting time something about the
retrieval system I thought you said it
once that they dropped the couple yeah
there was a they missed a couple and I
think one of them just sank and the
other one had we had a on some recovery
missions we had helicopters flying under
the recovery airplanes and so one of
them was picked up by a helicopter one
of the buckets console is Jeanne covert
your supposition is correct
can't see except that it was Brezhnev's
nephew that was rough
okay was it really you know myself
position I was a pure gas and I didn't
know where and the program I just said
there's somebody who runs that program
who has connectors so no is that really
a factory I'll be goddamn that's the
first time I've heard about well I was
involved in it I have a question about
the NRO but I have to make a comment
before the you'd mentioned Samos yes
right and that ran during the 1950's and
it was a combined ICBM Tamara do
everything right satellite product and
right after the Russian Sputnik in
September 57 Eisenhower became concerned
about the speed of Aetna and his
immediate advisors that we should look
at the model of the u2 program which the
CIA ran in a very streamlined fashion
Vista affiliate satellite program so he
started planning between in December of
of 57 through the end of December 58 all
the briefings at high level were totally
verbal because of the sensitivity of the
competition they knew was going to erupt
they went out for proposals in January
of 1958 the proposals were in the
contractors were selected by the
beginning of April program was funded by
the middle of April specifications were
begun a month later and the
specifications were set in country did
you totally ridiculous
The Impossible Project anyway the
program succeeded as you described so
but after the NRO began I think 13 on
successful launches before the first
plane in August of 1960 those were in
the so-called discovered programs or
some of you may remember I anyway the
FBN arrow got going the CIA was very
angry about it they wanted to preserve
their turf because they thought they've
done a good job and during the the first
time use of the NRO the infighting was
absolutely fierce oh I have to tell you
it was fierce when I was there and that
was 12 years after they'd been published
oh yeah declassified history of the NRL
between 1960 1965 which is goes
blow-by-blow but it's absolutely
fascinating well it was the same same
infighting but look it was very good
because it again you know it's
interesting that competition in the
private sector is admired it makes for
efficiency competition in the public
sector is called duplication and ok and
we have to cut out duplication now why
people in the public sector are
motivated by different things and people
in the private sector I don't understand
that the fact that we had competition
between different agencies in the NRO
that participated in our own between the
military agencies and the civil agencies
actually made the agency as good as it
was I thought there's no question about
that in my mind we would not have had
the quality of the people like bud we on
was a contemporary mine here in graduate
school in that program if it weren't for
that competitive element there's no
question about it and and you know
competition leads to problems and the
director had to adjudicate between some
very very aggressive people and that led
to a few interesting discussions could
you say anything about the knowledge
1955 to 257 concerning the preparations
prep the the state of the their
capabilities fifty five to fifty five to
two fifty seven and capabilities in the
space in the military well I know I
can't really I mean that's a that's a
tough question that requires a very long
answer I can't say much
I was wondering about the consequences
of that first YouTube that was shut down
I mean I know that people saw it was
coming but still as the US airplane shot
by were shut down by the Russians so
like they did that have any political
consequences or you know just well it
was it was a little more than that I
mean it was a u.s. airplane that we flew
secretly and never publicly talked about
and it was even even more amusing
because it was flown by NASA undercover
what no I'm sorry it was by NASA ok NASA
was the cover and the thing that was
interesting is that when NASA was called
up and said what's all this about your
you - they said what are you talking
about they didn't know they were the
cover so but the answer to your question
is that that it was a covert flight and
so and the Russians of course knew it
because he could see him with radar and
and visually and they finally developed
the rocket that could shoot it down that
was the
okay hi Scott Shannon this was wondering
what you would say about the security
issues involved with the availability of
high-resolution reconnaissance now to
anyone online and also high-resolution
DPS coordination well you know that's
also a very complicated question the
real issue is targeting that is that is
how do you use a combination of the
things that you talked about to target
to use as a targeting device for
military operations and the answer of
course is that you can do it now it's
not easy so I I'm not sure that anybody
except ourselves right now have the
sustained capability to do that but it's
certainly there in the open and we have
to assume that a lot of other people are
going to learn how to do this really
quickly we used it in Kosovo for sure as
you know
League Ronson's how are you good if it
weren't for that light I would have seen
you and this is a technical question
you're being a technical nerd I have to
ask you a technical question and I've
been brooding throughout your talk about
this counter-rotating system of two
cameras yes and how the hell you do a
stereoscopic vision with that oh you
don't do it with a stereoscopic can I
can see this area scopic hey hey hey I
did not mean to imply that you don't use
those two pictures what you do this
thing walks along okay you just write
okay thanks it's it's from you get the
stereoscopic picture from different
revolutions or listening yep maybe he
could one number with you some of this
photography toward the end and a
resolution the ground of about five feet
you only saw the the people lined up for
Lenin's tomb because they were in a line
anyway some of this photography which
was on about a si to black and white
film very high resolution film very very
slow would stand up to 40 times
magnification the negative was roughly
three inches by the 29 inches 40 times
and made a print it's no one in his
right mind was done you would have had a
print ten feet high and eighty feet long
and it would have been shot from corner
to corner that is the the combination of
this very slow film and a nice stable
platform that isn't shaking the nerve
but that that's a number to remember and
that in fact the concepts that you
talked about were possible you mentioned
that the caspian sea monster and we and
we couldn't produce some admittedly
we're farming open society and on the
state sort of got known and we didn't
have staffs people and satellites but we
had the nuclear airplane and there was a
family and right right right
madison and there were two lodged raid
has built up in north dakota and if it
weren't open the russians would have won
that also but louis we never built a
nuclear powered airplane they didn't
build the caspian sea by we could we did
put a lot of money
general donald putt remember him he was
a major general and that was that the
the argument for the nuclear power derek
plane i remember vividly was like this
nuclear power is good it was good for
submarines it must be good for airplanes
that was the whole justification that
went into it well those who know how
smart no we could not give a talk
without talking about nuclear or
something just as i can't be a chairman
without asking about man in space Huss
mark went when i in skipping through his
bio i did not mention that haunts was
deputy administrator of the National
Aeronautics and Space Administration
during the period when he was in under
his watch where they got the shuttle
program launched and the first of the
beginning of the beginning of the
beginning of the space nation the cover
story that we were told or the story we
were to we were told in the civilian
sector those of us involved with the
Space Shuttle was that the Space Shuttle
would have been doomed because of
overruns were it not the fact that for
the fact that President Carter was
convinced it was necessary for
verification of salt - how does that fit
in with the aerial reconnaissance of the
satellite Rakata look I was there
precisely at the moment when that
decision was made in fact I have a
picture of the president in the Cabinet
Room
Frank press was sitting next to him on
one side Harold Brown was on the other I
was next to Frank Bob frosh was next to
Harold and the question was look every
new administration that comes in wants
to cancel something you know you have to
show that the last guys were dumb and so
you need to cancel something the issue
was the shuttle or the b1 okay and it
fell to us to go in and persuade the
president to keep the shuttle and it was
really a combination of reasons one of
the reasons of course was that the
shuttle was in fact sized to carry the
most capable reconnaissance satellites
we had but I think it went it went
deeper than that it was a I remember
that Harold
okay Harold Brown can be exceedingly
eloquent and Harold was the guy in that
meeting who carried the day for the
space shuttle because he said mr.
president you know you've heard all the
national security requirements and and
so on and I agree with them and they're
fine but I also know you could do that
some other way you know that there are
other ways you could you could get those
things into into orbit
the real reason Harold said is that
somehow it is in our destiny in our
genes to put people in space and to go
explore and this vehicle is the first
thing to do it now
you know b1 he said also he fought for
the b1 when he was secretary secretary
of the Air Force but he said that's just
not as important and that was the way
that decision was made
okay let me thank you once again tell
the audience that there is there are
some refreshments to the back of the
room and I hope that dr. Marc will stick
around with us for for for a few minutes
thereafter well brief announcement this
lecture is part of the course modern
space science and engineering which will
continue next week as usual is always
welcome
shortly know our plane how it happened
because when it was obvious at first our
firefighters you know got comment to not
to get it but it was unreachable and
nobody knows why but
commanded to return back one did not
maybe he wants to be a hero
maybe he didn't hear Sun and the rock
the missile targeted him and it is
because power survived it is obvious and
all the you know these powers this is
our firefighters this is rocket and this
is you know this sound way it is first
time I mentioned this I know the veto
it's possible
[Applause]